team Brown got emotional on stage last
night at the CMT Artists of the Year
event as a paid tribute to his drummer
Kenny Dixon who died in a car crash on
Saturday
yeah Kane was Kane has canceled his
concert in LA this Friday but he felt
that it was important to show up for the
awards last night so he could honor
Kenny here's what Kane said on stage I
want to dedicate this to my drummer
Kenny
[Applause]
[Music]
he uh he started with this he started
with me coming out of Chattanooga all
Facebook people didn't think we would
make it he was with me he was so
supportive of me and I love man I miss
you the band misses you
god bless you guys y'all stay safe go go
yeah so yeah that's the thing they four
days ago yeah he passed away and so I
mean good on Kane for still going to
that work so no one would have blamed
them you see what's been longer they
choose the who's gonna get the awards
you know I don't know a couple months in
advance
yeah it's not surprising you're gonna
win the award but yeah no one would have
blamed Kane if he decided not to come
because yeah he has cancels constant
Friday yeah yeah extremely difficult and
someone pointed out to that Reba was
there I remember that he was like 1991
they're like eight of Reba's band or
crew died yeah playing yes she was there
last night as well so and Thomas Rhett
did a prayer on stage it was a very
emotional I definitely do the same T's
but yeah Cooper came to go and it also
for Cain you know to show up and do it
on that stage in front of that many
people I know he's canceled concerts but
he will eventually get back on stage and
doing it there on that stage in front of
that many people with the television
audience sort of saves him from
repeating it every night so now when he
does a show fans are gonna be going at
the end of the show and he didn't say
any right you know it was kind of weird
that he didn't say no that's true right
and so to do it on that level with with
you know getting that much of an
audience for it sort of you know allows
him to return to the stage to to
entertain fans without having the
pressure to do that over and over and
over again Peter says real men cry oh my
god friend died this was so heartfelt
yeah beautify Nance's I was crying so
hard when I watch that yeah Georgia says
aw yeah no it's